I have a dream I'll pay mistakes but
mistakes make you strong hey guys
welcome to D LM model lifestyle I'm
Daniel and I've been a male model for
over 12 years now some of you guys that
starting out modeling you asked me hey
Daniel we need some help with the model
portfolio how should it look like so in
this video I'm gonna show you my model
portfolio example and what I want you
guys to look at is the different
expressions of the different flows that
I have on with the different light of
the photographer's using all of those
things they play together so let's not
waste any more time let's get into
[Music]
[Music]
like you be strong to hold the powers of
the Sun
[Music]
to dream believe in strength now I'm the
only warning
[Music]
in the mud
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's it for the model
portfolio if you have any other
questions about anything else about
modeling check out my modeling ebook in
the video description down below if you
liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
Cheers
[Music]